I'm at the summit of Mount Evans in
Colorado USA it is one of the Colorado
14s meaning I am more than 14,000 feet
above sea level
as Americans measure it for the rest of
the world paddies 4.3 kilometres above
sea level or about halfway to an
airplanes cruising altitude and the air
up here is thin I'm only getting about
60% of the oxygen that I normally do
each time I breathe in and let me tell
you this was a difficult climb at least
the last bit of it was because this is
also the most American mountain because
there is a road to the top of it the
highest paved road in North America and
this summit here counts as the 41st
highest mountain in North America but
how do we count that just over there the
wonderfully named Maya bumble
observatory it on another slightly lower
summit but it's surrounded by lower
ground why doesn't count as the 42nd
highest and you might say all the
answers obvious it's part of the sign
mounted but where does that pinned this
summit Mount Evans is just a smaller
part of a big mountain range so you
could try and make the case that this is
just a bump on the way to the tallest
peak in the Rockies Mount Elbert or you
could take it to the extreme and say
that there's only one mountain on each
landmass but every other peak in North
America is just a small bump on the way
to the enormous constant sized mountain
called Denali now that's ridiculous most
people would say if it's obvious that's
a mountain and that isn't but in formal
terms we solve it by measuring
prominence prominence works like this
imagine if you could raise sea level up
to where I'm sitting now how many meters
would it have to drop before you could
connect this mountain to another taller
one and walk there without getting your
feet bite from Mount Evans that is 839
meters down or about one-fifth of its
height above sea level that observed
free summit over there it's not
prominent sure you have to walk downhill
from it but after a few meters you go on
uphill again so where do you draw the
line well there are several different
lines because of course there are the
International climbing and
mountaineering Federation defined the
mountain as needing three hundred meters
of prominence which is actually only the
height of the Eiffel Tower
which doesn't seem like much to me other
folks disagree inside should be 500
meters or that prominence should change
with altitude it's a mess I'll be honest
enough for researching this I'm
sure about it even the folks have to
check my script when oh yeah well I
guess basically but technically this is
one of those times but the human need to
categorize and catalogue everything runs
up against messy reality there are
always edge cases and pretty much every
mountain is an educator I'm going to go
back down on the floor again perpetuate
sickness